okay why do you what's up to talk to my
Asian friends
to talk to my Chinese bot friends
[Music]
does anybody here know what a Sim
swapper is a what Brian does I is that
some kind of fraud thing you do with
cards it is a fraud thing oh I thought I
was talking about the Sims the game and
[__] you trade your [__] Sims so this
this has to do with like Sim like phone
numbers there's this dude named Amir
Hussein golshan who allegedly broke into
influencers Instagram accounts not just
for financial game but also to sex start
the victims anymore yeah he uh is that
the new [__] that people are doing now
yeah it um men are mad that women are
making more money than them
but there's also one where like like
they they catfish you and then you send
them a video of you jacking off and then
they'll be like pay or shame yeah yeah
if they catfish you they say hi I'm your
doctor I need a video through jacking
off and then
they pretend to be a girl or whatever
and then you're being intimate with them
get honeypotted basically yeah and I
told all my friends you gotta [__]
have a real face time with them but they
don't they gonna do this one's real yeah
it's really it's a real girl that
doesn't even respond to you they do a
really good job of making you believe
it's a real girl no I think people just
no I think they're pretty bad like there
are so many people being like hey babe I
need your help and I'm like what they're
like I got locked out of my um like
Instagram or something like that and
like I need a code sent to your phone
they need to verify and I'm like all the
people falling for that I'm like does
that even sound it sounds like English
was not their first language exactly
yeah I got one yesterday that was like
hey I made a beautiful home-cooked meal
do you want to come over and I was like
kind of a little bit yeah that sounds a
little that was a new one like I haven't
heard that what was the home cooking
it's very wholesome no I should have
asked it's really wholesome damn yeah
all right it could have been anything
I'd be getting all these Chinese girls
on my WhatsApp and [__] they send like a
group picture like do you have an
Android no okay why do you have WhatsApp
to talk to my Asian friends
[Laughter]
after my Chinese bot friends it's big to
talk to people like uh no it's like like
internationally like yeah it's just
easier if they don't have iPhone and
stuff yeah yeah I shame people with
Androids
you should yeah I should wait so the so
the Sim swap thing do you get to is it
to access their iCloud and like stored
uh photos well actually he would extort
them by more so taking over their
accounts and these are influencers
female influencers so you oh then you
can see all their DMS and [__] huh and
then he would he basically hit him up
and be like do you want your account
back if you do you need to get on a
video call with me and you need to like
strip tea oh he does what like that yeah
he does that version and he just jacks
off that's like freaking True Lies yeah
so so he extorts them if they want their
account back so then one you know one of
the victims that's in this court case
right she like same thing he she gets on
a video call complies to the whole thing
oh she does oh they caught him well
she's like you know strip teasing and
doing different things that he wants and
then he masturbates and whatnot you know
does she at least get her account back
and he gives her the account back but
then because he has her info right he
gives her the account back and then
proceeds to continue asking her out to
like dinner or like
dinner
but then after she continues to reject
him when he when she like rejects him
like the last time or whatever yeah he
still has like the verification assigned
back into her account Jackson again then
deletes it you know why he got caught
it's because some girl was like I'm
gonna go to dinner with this guy and he
actually shows up like oh dude here's my
chance and then yeah I'm gonna marry
this chick
is like okay I remember in high school
when we had home girls right and they
were going through issues with weird
guys or whatever they would just tell us
and we would handle it and I'm like why
I thought girls would have so many
brothers or guy friends that would help
them with this kind of stuff to be fair
my brother I feel like I would have to
fight people for him
how old is your brother he's
he's I I act like I've always acted like
the older so it's like I'm the one
fending off people got it he must be
five nine no I think he's like almost
six foot he's just he was homeschooled a
lot so I'm the one fighting people for
him he's six he can't use it
maybe it's also hard because it's a
digital world too yeah
she needs no hackers and [__] and the
Sim swap thing I don't know how they do
it now but I do know that back in the
day because I used to work at [__]
basically Verizon an employee could
actually do that [__] whoa yeah an
employee can do it so they'll probably
work for like a lot of employees they
help with like you know the clear scams
yeah those are done through corrupt
employees of which there's tons of them
this is probably through a t no you make
way more money like helping people do
scams and actually working at Verizon oh
my God or Geek Squad I know or Geek
Squad yeah right like if you take your
computer to get fixed at a place they
can look through all yours whenever I
went to Sprint when I used to have
Sprint you know how you had to leave
your phone for them to fix it and [__]
when it was cracked and stuff I always
go no they're [__] jacking off to me
at the store they're [__] looking
behind the counter as they're talking to
you I know they're air dropping my [__]
dude
they're taking pictures well it's just
like back in the day when you had to get
film developed like people had to look
at it yeah they're looking at all your
stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah that's so true
I'm picking up at Costco oh yeah dude so
um we when we were doing graffiti like
we would take those [__] disposable
camera pictures right and then one day I
think like my mom was just grabbing up
all the film to just
um what do you call develop develop
right and she said that when she got
mine the person had like a face of she
just saw death
and then she's like I was wondering why
and I was like oh yeah those are my
graffiti pictures so the old lady that
was processing the film was just sitting
here watching me posing next to my
[__] paintings and everything just
like yeah
dude I got him here too it's hilarious
yeah that needs to be a slime ladies
fall for judging dude yeah find her
[__] business you know she shouldn't
go to a Christian CVS
no it was like a mom and pop one that
she went to where you get like passport
photos it's funny though it's like your
mom's picking up the photos and she's
like looking at your mom like does this
person know that her son yeah but I bet
on the scale of things that they've
developed they've seen way crazy they
probably seen some [__] up [__] yeah
the only option A bunch of photos that
are like me on E with my eyes rolled
back and [__] like Vapor Rub all over
my me too dude I have so many of those
videos but also at the time though a lot
of photos if you didn't shoot it right
remember how the whole red eye thing
like they would always be [__] up
anyway yeah oh that's true you know red
eye thing no you don't it's gone now
that's not even an issue yeah it's just
like everything's perfect Now versus The
Flash that always was in your eyes dude
you know it's a crazy ass story there's
a there was a mom and pops film shop in
Downey like super old like a it's a they
sell like vintage cameras things like
that would just go in there to [__]
around and look at stuff and then I the
owner is like a one of those guys that's
owned the store for like four years or
something and he's like talking to me oh
what do you do we were just shooting the
[__] and I told him like Oh I'm a dancer
blah blah and he goes hey do you know uh
there's this one dancer that that came
in here years ago and never picked up
his photos and he's like maybe you know
him I'm like I probably don't if he's
like super old and then um he goes no
yeah you might know him because I think
he's like famous and he told me and I
knew the guy he was like yeah tell him
his photos are here and I'm like what
photos did he leave and he goes photos
from when he was on tour with Michael
Jackson what holy
he just left them there in like the
early 90s wow did you end up talking
like yeah yeah well I didn't know him
directly because he's like super high up
there so I went through a friend and I
was like can you tell him his photos are
still there I wonder if he just got high
and forgot
that's amazing
it's funny though you know like back in
the day like you had to be really rich
to have video cams right so people took
pictures of dancers and it doesn't look
like anything you have like mid-motion
right I have a camera that has yet to be
developed and it's so old
it's between 2000 and 2010.
but I don't know what era or anything I
haven't developed it yet why I don't
know I just like just develop it just
keep moving and stuff whatever and I
just thought oh I'll do this later you
know the box that I'll do later you
should develop that's a good episode
yeah we'll see what's on it yeah an
unboxing of your old yeah yeah yeah and
we all look at the same time yeah okay a
reveal we should it's all just we need
to stop we need to start at the
developing place so we get the reaction
of the guy that hands me them let's see
what it's like that's the next Jake
gotta find the most Christian [__]
developing Studio yeah and get the
reaction live on camera It's gotta be
like in Utah or something then yeah we
gotta find some Christian developers
we're gonna find some SDA developers
Christian Photo developers
meanwhile over here she's sending me
[__] videos for rolly yeah
I scanned it
let's see who's out there I guarantee
mine's uglier dude okay I send them to
you who's got the ugliest one all right
this one first yeah all right this is
her where's Joe
well we'll see him later now he Judy has
a box yeah I'm a [__] you brought my
box oh my gosh oh wait this ain't the
one how old are you
look at mine look at this that was me
rolling
what the [__] is that no this is me
randomly Googling ugliest man in the
world oh my
I don't think he's that ugly
I want to see I want to see I don't know
why I Googled it by Google the ugliest
man in the world back in the day this is
just ask me how hard I'm rolling oh [__]
look at that this face look at that jaw
dude oh
[__] those blueberries
that was Project Z I believe how old is
that that video uh that was
2017 I think oh okay okay yeah before I
got my boobs on
so this one this one's funny too I was
like trying to stay low-key
I like how it says trying to stay
low-key
oh
that jaw dude and I'm guessing the next
one is after you got your boobs done
this was like really
recently
[__] Joey
who's Joey yeah who's Joey because I
should have been a really good friends
he wasn't answering me
[__] Joey
Joey would you would you like to see the
world's first three selfies ever taken
a lot of selfies that's my dad's name my
name would be gatherer
[Music]
foreign